du rimbaud dont je serai tout seul pour
vous commandez latran des vous quotidien
de 2 13 heures c'est un réel qui va
commencer de nos un quart d'heure va
jouer en 3 + 2 donc je vais vous mettre
le lien dans le chat si quelqu'un pour
le confirmer à tout moment dans une
jatte que tout fonctionne bien et déjà
une première fois
en attendant on a quand même du
spectacle et des médias voire je vous
contraint me rend mercredi en blitz
du coup même les joueurs de top niveau
sauf que pendant le confinement alors
est ce que je suis bien live un petit
test pour vérifier
n'hésitez pas à me dire si vous voyez la
roma est parfait merci beaucoup
alors je passe à l'échiquier salut à
quito ça lui revenait donc n'hésitez pas
à vous inscrire il ya déjà une quinzaine
de personnes dont commandes dont 20 dans
un petit quart d'heure et attendant on
va regardons s'ils possèdent parti el
arkam assez sympa à série de chaises qui
se fait attaquer sa vue berly sa vue
barbe de bronze joli pseudo barbe de
bombes j'espère que tu joues tournoi
j'irai pouvoir alors ici les plans
annoncés latin classique à base de
vaches quatre tout de suite pour
empêcher son adversaire 2
de rentrer sur le droit de changer plus
fous la joueuse tchèque un petit échec à
retarder des comptes chez les noirs mais
pour le moment les clôtures ont passé
des blonds ya pas tant de soucis que
saïda bien bloqué cavaliers c'est le
meilleur des bloqueurs salut et anne et
on voit que le voir essayer de prendre
un peu d espace à la dame ce qu'ils ont
un 3e il ya plus étroites un peu faible
mais du coup quand même space est le
grand maître indien
je connais pas mais doivent être mauvais
déjà il a gagné la première contre autre
mamelle
alors je vous remets le lien vu que
avait pas la c1 trois clubs français
dont il faut juste est membre du club
français au s'inscrire ça se complique
ok donc stop qui gêne le pseudo de barbe
de bronze
c'est aussi créatif pour créer des
pseudo quel que soit le format un retour
à la partie du coup ici salaire quand
même assez prometteur pour les blancs le
voit que les noirs sont vraiment troué
sur cases noires au point qu'il
abandonne moi ça me semble prématuré
après il est très fort mais quand même
ils avaient des défenseurs chez par un
petit peu plus être de la partie
azarov d'abandonner aussi vite
alors mon gré fallen est ce que on doit
aller vous voit maintenant le code en
fait on met une fois pour toutes
a priori rien
c'est pareil pour youtube et une fois
qu'on l'a on la rend très normalement
normalement tu es tranquille pour la
suite je suis pas encore du tout indique
star à niveau technique mais c'est
bizarre je dois me mettre à chaque fois
je pense que kevin sera à nous de les
diviser comme moi mais c'est
relativement pas normal normalement tu
as juste à me mettre une seule fois
alors un petit peu des gens qui
s'inscrivent pour le moment notre numéro
un ça c'est un faux rue saint-louis
melquiot
je le connais un joueur très prometteur
encore très jeune mais qui fait de
grosses performances
du coup les fichiers bout malgré son
drapeau russe il est bien français et on
verra si son pseudo 1 ce dernier film
d'abadan verts dont il faudra se
déshabituer dit vu lui aussi l'homme a
souvent je vais toujours les premiers
rôles dans ses arènes
oui effectivement c'est peut-être une
histoire de coups qui met le lire soit
qu'ils ont besoin ça doit venir de
l'arrêt du coup vont pouvoir régler le
problème assez facilement sinon avait
aussi ça rime qui jouent et donc notre
petit prodige indien de 15 ans qui en
train de jouer contre un ami russe
quelques unes vardenafil ici voit qu'ils
disent et demi à 6 ennemis donc fait
respecter sa supériorité au rebond et
l'eau simonet une finale dames ne tarde
pas forcément des plus passionnantes
mais ça peut être intéressant de voir
exception de plus comment ils arrivent à
gagner
ces lits par an en fait le gros avantage
de ce pion c'est juste que son roi aura
aucun problème de sécurité et souvent en
finales de dames le risque principal se
trouve à perpète
en l'occurrence iqra rien il a un pion
pas s'éloigner
donc de là à gagner ça va être encore
très technique mais je ne pense qu
objectivement il devrait être gagnant un
ciel
et surtout que la table doivent dominer
domine celle d'anne blanche les plus
possible et l'ajustage vous en faites b4
v3 dame ces deux îles vanille et très
facilement
donc il ressasse a bien joué et c'est
notamment de provoquer le courroux des
coupes le pion et avec les plans c'est
sa meilleure chance sauf que juste on
court plus vite ici si fait 17 juste on
mange la dame et caen 2e dame apparaît
il ya toujours le pont b qui va à gênés
du coup il a logiquement logements
abandonnés alors c'est une arnaque aux
connards salut à toi qui est encore une
fois juste réservé cette fois aux
français
et oui je suis tout ça est qu'au prix
d'été des partis camper sur ce combat
pro avec lena puisque ce qu'il faisait
ça un peu non stop depuis ces trois
semaines donc je pense qu'il avait
besoin de couper un petit peu mais aller
aux besoins pas je pense lundi et demain
vous devriez avoir femme a priori tout
seul au style donc qu'aucun à gagner ici
après ceux qui étaient là hier s'il
fallait vraiment préféré vous mélangez
avec avec des gens de toutes les
nationalités pour faire un gros tournoi
le joueur
dites-nous le real à venir aux dames
savent pas ce que ce que vous préférez
n'hésitez pas nous lâcher un petit
retour par rapport à ça c'est vrai comme
moi ça va ça change un petit peu aussi
peut-être d'adversaires ses parents de
le france rires de raser toutes les
premières places
il ya c'était pas mal par contre ça
durait plus longtemps quand c'était deux
heures cette arène les progrès zirn
toile
je crains de ne pas pouvoir y faire
grand chose si c'est le cas jusqu'au
niveau sont même c'est de régler ça
euh ok ok vous verrez un simple pour la
prochaine fois s'il a moyen de la
qualité du son je t'embrasse
allez les bleus allez les veux tu dois
être membre du club français c'est pas
déjà 46 avenue albert cohen et goguenard
on commence dans sept minutes à une
heure et quart pour l'instant on a déjà
35 points inscrits donc sam bien là et
c'est anne cavani qui ferme la marche au
niveau élevé de faire déjouer avec nous
et pour le moment c'est toujours notre
petit russe lui le chiot part favori sur
le papier des balades vertes et mauvais
polar très dangereux je viens de
mentionner des mutuelles
la dj crew grob sûrement nous assurer le
spectacle
ok à
un petite taille à la partie de sound
vous savez que c'est pas les parties les
plus spectaculaires qui nous propose en
tout cas les deux regards de regarder
c'est plutôt très technique laisser
intéressant otis palu frau kick
alors non quand une fois réussi à
gratter un pion aux puces de la d'une
meilleure structure davantage de tueur
isolé chez les blancs après il pourra
chasser le cac valeo m3 bahreïn en avant
postes ce tableau au moins cinq ans s
est un peu faible ou quand vous encore
une fois ça demande quand même une
grosse technique pour gagner ça je pense
que ça arrive même si j'aime bien il
s'entraîne énorme bond à la tactique ou
des gares de tactique va la preuve les
muses parfaitement un petit pesait une
petite fourchette qui va lui simplifier
la vie puisqu'il ya un deuxième show
pense qu'il donne énormément aussi
poussé les finales et donc vous faire
preuve de beaucoup de technique alors
attention ils arrivent à reperdre des
5es le bagne pour l'instant c'est qu'ils
doivent tous très actifs cette tour donc
ça ça c'est bien joué
ainsi qu'à la fin il aura tout ce 4ème
avance que les blancs doivent calculer
c'est ce qui donne une chance dans la
finale de roi sauf que si j'avais à tour
à quatre on va changer la tour et le
pion risque hommes de coin vite alors 34
certaine il a pris il a réfléchi trois
rounds sarine faux calcul final dow a
gelé très confiant est-ce que des cinq
ne gagne pas après moi je respecte il va
juste faire un pion base et des deux
côtés laurent blanc il peut pas du tout
coup et un deuxième à la fois remonte du
coup il va griller facile salut alfredo
la chambre glas et sa lubie d'oydes
alors dit moi je dis finale de trois
buts au final d'options est aussi
toujours des options pour une finale
finale de roi qu'il n'y a plus d'autres
pièces
sont a priori les plus faciles à
calculer puisque pour le coup c'est
vraiment du temps par ton coin alors
qu'est ce que je pense de deux cavaliers
f3 sur la seconde hidhab pas grand chose
pour l'instant je vois ce que c'est là
en fait je connais pas du tout tours
gambie schéma génie que doit y avoir des
décompensations plus ou moins évidentes
mais je sais vraiment pas d'expérience
eu beaucoup kevin la scandinave c'est
son dada
alors la reine à 13h15 le futur on va
bientôt commencer
et cette fois ci c'est juste entre nous
je pense qu'on emballe card et à
l'avenir de temps en temps vous dira se
greffer dans une arène fixe déjà de
temps en temps vous restera entre
joueurs français important au final
devoir a bien évolué et juste sign qui
nous montre est un athlète et qui court
beaucoup plus vite que son adversaire
qui devrait abandonner
il manque un temple ans je vous parle
grand chose pour à l'escorté l'option
référendum sur et chaque mais souvent
les finales de deux rois ce jour home
depot a way jour contre chelsea alors
français c'est très sain on passe de
lille à un clic salles de bingo salle de
ce mot là à partir de ce normalement
vous pouvez rejoindre le club français
et ensuite
et ensuite le tournoi
je vais vous remettre ici c'est lui le
gaffeur dg et will bedoya alors du coup
il reste deux minutes barrage on aboutit
coupe qui a invité surprise par me
devais pas jouer finalement il vient
vient de montrer son talent un petit peu
elle qu'un d'appariement choc vu sommé
de sica pour commencer
will crèche ou une poupée poupe deux
meilleurs 0 pour l'instant on n'était
pas aussi de temps en temps je regarde
pas systématiquement si quelqu'un
demande de lire notre édtion à me donner
à ma place du coup on va regarder cette
dernière partie de sa marine aux suite
ce sera à votre tour d'être autiste
alors l'écart relativement ça a quand
même son adversaire est entre guillemets
que amy et les pas si nombreux que ça ça
arrive comme un petit prodige d'internet
qui joue énormément et je vais très très
vite une grosse pression et souvent
c'est blitz à make up est encore à la
peau dure donc là il profite du cloître
ils attaquent une troisième fois ce
cavalier et du coup il va encore gagner
parce que il y aura juste un échec à la
découverte intermédiaires et ensuite il
pourra se permettre de reprendre la
pièce il ya les cas la durée de
l'enquêté rigolo mais qui fonctionnait
pas alors la reine devrait se lancer si
quelques secondes va arrêter de regarder
les sarine
ce que c'est parti oui allez on va
regarder le premier le premier chèque
puis ensuite j'aurai je touchais un peu
partout où la pop hip hop qui se
montrent très pédagogue avec ce fond h
au premier coup ou comme admis prison
alors les deux joueurs se connaissent
bien vous colle à une parapsychologiques
mais je rappelle que c'est du 3 pouces
de donc mettre la pression autant est
pas suffisant faut aussi bien jouer sur
l'échiquier époux pipou qui pompe et un
32 premières on va voir si oui le crush
ue le punit et son pseudo est
annonciateur de la punition a priori non
en tout cas ça mérite mais dans les
faits c'est pas si facile de de réfuter
qu'on notre adversaire je veux un truc
un peu douteuse
et se met à faire des choix logique car
là il sacrifie lampions on se disant qui
va certainement le récupérer par la
suite parce que des 80 est faible mais
[Musique]
c'est quand même assez risqué peut-être
celle d'anne deux intermédiaires où les
blancs où il a préféré embaucher tout de
suite c'est quand même assez moche
positionnelle mort il ya des trous et
des trous partout
toute la structure de pions des droits
est sûre case blanche
du coup les gaz mans sont un peu trop et
je pense que le pompier poupe se faire
un peu trop le malin pour l'instant
alors qu'est ce qui se passe sur mon jeu
l'option des 4 le problème c'est qu'il
est veuf ou prendre six derrière va
perdre on va perdre le pion leroy d'être
exposé donc pour train peut pas se
permettre d'aller récupérer son pion du
coup table 2 c'était très dangereux de
la part de démouville cruciaux et ben
non il a juste un peu plus et les
compensations qui voient avec et donc
pipe on doit trouver une solution ici
alors dams est comme un gros tas de
faiblesses ici on va juste prendre avec
les blancs et jaunes avec un truc plus
une meilleure structure est ce que pour
lui si c'est un pur arrière est qui est
vraiment très faible la légère
compensation des douars c'est lorsque
leur fouquet pour l'instant supérieure
vous fout des blancs mais c'est très
loin de la diffusant les styles et les
blonds sont relativement écrasant salut
art il
et si vous lui crache où il arrive juste
à jouer des coups simples la rocqué a
stabilisé il devrait pouvoir l'emporter
à baguida ça peut venir si tu
t'entraînes tu te perds des outils
notamment de leçons français qui sont
pas mal alors bien sûr si c'est pas du
jour au lendemain
c'est un niveau débutant qui vient juste
de débuter le temps c'est assez logique
ces joueurs là ils ont mis des dizaines
d'années avant d'atteindre le niveau qui
est là t'as aucune logique gras après la
logique aux échecs et relativement
vieillit pas
y'a pas que ça a souvent d'assaut aussi
peut-être à tort les échecs et les
battre moi je suis pas persuadé de cette
connexion elle peut exister bien sûr on
peut être pour combattre et aux échecs
il sait absolument pas obligatoire c'est
une forme aussi quand même très
importante de créativité dans cette
partie où il crèche où il va devoir en
faire grandement traves de créativité
parce que comme vous pouvez le voir sont
fous de gaz doivent but sur un mur de
deux pions et il ne manque qu'un pion
rêves celle d'un sans raison je suis
perdue sont par contre le gall alliés
blanc lui peut se régaler la juste 4 4 4
qui domine complètement fou va
certainement y installant des six mais
en fait ils espèrent certainement ça
c'est un bon conseil
quand vous êtes sous pression c'est de
sacrifier est une qualité pour un pion
pour ouvrir leurs ennemis pour changer
la dynamique de l'imposition et mieux
vaut jouer avec une qualité de moi mais
un peu d'activité que d'être juste et
tout fait doublage le pense qu'il
devrait mangeant des six ce qui peut
citer d'autres
alors il veut préparer pour rester en
plongée six étaient très faibles
c'est un principe à l'idée à leur guise
pour progresser si tu veux progresser
tout seul le mieux sont vraiment deux
si tu joues et tu as raison 6,85 ce qui
joue contre toi même tu auras du mal à
prononcer les six n'ont pas vraiment les
leçons qu'ils sont bien utiles aux sons
et les exercices tactiques vous
entraîner au calcul des problèmes
d'abord d'un niveau assez facile petit à
petit je me montre la difficulté d'être
forcé à calculer en fait habitué au
cerveau à réfléchir de manière un peu
comme la géométrie spatiale de projeter
salutiste 85 alors les noix qui sont aux
grandes souffrances mais qui met un peu
la pression autant je doute que celle
suffisent pour l'instant alors ils
essayent de contre-attaqué en mettant
triple pression et moi tout simplement
vous g3 est parfaite cette chaîne de
cube blanc j'allais très fort parce que
juste est la ville complètement tout
pouvoir de souhaits l'accenture quoi
fourrage calquer très bien joué zhai du
tout contre je tenais là que ce fou pour
elle réfléchit qu'est ce serait presque
pareil changera pas grand chose donc
pour l'instant c'est une démonstration
pour un professionnel de stratégique et
will très chiant mais petite poupée
plein de responsables arabes unis
poussent le paroxysme
l'écrasement de la la position et quand
je vous disais que moi avec les noix
j'aurais bien aimé sacrifier ben tour où
j'aurais pu surfer cavaliers on sera le
match ben c'est devenu impossible et
certainement qu'ils le regrettent
alors maintenant il reste à passer c'est
à dire que ici d'abord améliorer tout
l'art leur pièce à la perfection
il faut maintenant réussir à percer et
pour ça par exemple mais c'est de mettre
la pression sur ceux qui ont l'avantagé
ici c'est con
ce qu'on appelle faire tourner les
pièces à dire gros risques j'habite à
rien avec le nom d'un compte en tant que
l'on veut pour s'organiser pour battre
devrait pour faire des petites menaces
jusqu'à ce que les douars finissent par
craquer là une idée c'est de tripler
dans la colonne b pour attaquer bessette
par exemple d'envoyer le pion b et à
tout moment où ils pourront aussi
essayer de switcher de jouer à la noire
ou rouge et 4 à condition de le préparer
et bill stream il est en vacances
ils seront opposés il campe je pense sur
son balcon avec lena d'un promeneur ou
le soleil y revient à roue de semaine
prochaine
parship à celle d'un stream prévu en
soir d'ailleurs c'est possible ou si
d'ici là à paris progresse petit à petit
avec les blancs la brochure deuxième
pion il est toujours aussi solide n'y a
aucun moyen pour aider loire de pénétrer
la position blanche
maintenant il valait ciblés ou qu'ils
vont le plomber cette veine le projet
directement
alors ça c'est plutôt bon jeu
pratiquement il a essayé d'activer sa
d'arbres avec les noirs pour pourquoi
pas chercher des échecs perpétuelle mais
c'était parfois un petit peu attention
dans malmo y aura pas de problème
mishima fouetter tyson gay encore que 29
sont à priori balle est plus fragile et
dangereux
alors oui c'est que l'on n'arrive pas à
transférer cette date il n'y a pas de
chemin en fait c'est beaucoup trop long
pour 1 il est embêté le roi et du coup
si les bleus ne se trouve pas normal ça
s'est extrêmement bien joué dans mais
c'est juste y forcent les changer d'âme
il a peut-être 7 8 mg bid pour garder
les dames
mais quand vous êtes gagnant vous avez
un large avantage mal
n'hésitez pas à privilégier les échanges
pour simplifier la position de
simplifier la vie sert à rien de vouloir
mourir au bar plus et donc ils
continuent cette fois ci la dame peut
pas s'échapper de son homologue et du
coup ils vaincront c'était les changes
dollar est certainement abandonné dans
la foule alors ça je te on va bien le
lien il y pense mais il est toujours là
bien sûr nombre qui plane au c'ur de nos
permanences à l'orias transposera au
final de roy est ici où quelque chose
juste un peu mauvais perdant au lieu
d'abandonner de pascal partie suivante
il vérifie que son adversaire c'est ma
tête ce qui a priori est le cas déjà vu
à l'oeuvre plusieurs fois et bas et la
turquie se battait avec une demeure donc
très belle victoire alors on va changer
de parti on va devoir peut-être pas
pâques
kalash puisque kalach il va nous
proposer de gala dont il a les plantes
c'est difficile et on a une finale de
fou contre un habitué cette future
turquie joue très souvent aussi
alors que katy est le seul coup pour
empêcher le roi de voir le cheval et
d'accéder à ce pion c5 puis occupé six
alors des fois le doit faire attention a
décidé comme fois ci si j'appelais le
fou samba du contrôle lagacé vite et
alors tout début je pensais que ça
allait être difficile pour les blancs et
finalement finalement repoussé à on sait
qu'avec les noirs devraient gagner en
maintenant il ya eu 6 il a complètement
craqué notre amicale h les finales
c'était pas son point fort elle poids
c'est que le roi il peut manger il reste
dans le car est donc maintenant il ya
quatre qui ont passé lié c'est au monde
trop tu fais juste avancer les pions de
cueillir celui ci mais à la base je
pense que ça allait pour les blancs il a
un petit peu craqué salut marc henry qui
l'a ratée fois ci soit voici ce qu'elle
remonte hippie dans le genre de position
alors on va descendre un petit peu et à
la banane verte balade verte qui est
toujours toujours au rendez vous
il affronte nice était rentable de la
bile points de plus mais on a vu qu'on
n'était pas à l'abri de grosses
surprises dans ses arènes d'une fois
donc vous reconnais quand même à
l'imposition la traditionnelle
scandinave habarcq de fabrique de la
panade
alors l'ex des coûts il a quand même
gagné le tour des quatre avec les noirs
donc déjà un gros avantage
et en plus quand même quand on a les
blancs ou même avoir un peu plus
d'espacé la sq ont donc que c'est un vin
il était un petit peu pas si le roi des
fois quand vous me contre un joueur
tient bien plus gros classement vous le
risque c'est d'essayer de jouer
justement très très solide pour se dire
ok je vais essayer de me résister le
plus longtemps possible mais dans la
réalité vous lui poserait plus de
problème si vous l'allaitez s'est voulu
rentrer dedans vous prenez des risques
allant d'une jolie tactique qui est plus
jolie d'ailleurs que si efficace que ça
mais ça procède à un échange en pet
alors ça c'était un mauvais pour
intermédiaires de la part de blanc parce
qu'à la fin il a strike peut s'attaquer
le fouet les cavaliers et du coup par la
force des choses il va aux bermudes et
donc raisonnablement il abandonne dans
la foulée alors on a barbarians qui
aussi
à me tuer mais barbarian vient de gagner
donc on va s'intéresser à d'autres
partis regardez un peu plus bas allez on
à angry d'acs a justement contre contre
d'un mariage est en grès des cadeaux que
les droits moi j'espérais un black
marque j'ai déjà repéré que le canard en
colère et un spécialiste barre et
poursuivra continent les blancs et on a
vu que c'est un joueur dangereux déjà à
plusieurs reprises il a été capable de
faire de belles perfs ou que barbarian
doit se méfier et la stratégie de la
reine façon ça on l'a vu dans les arènes
précédent de se jouer très vite ou
essayer d'accumuler le plus de parties
possible et marquer les points bas dit
faut pas que ce soit si défaitiste et un
peu tous les niveaux présidence est
alors resté principal hors jeu de la
position pleinement ça va être de faire
quelque chose de leur poussée vide qui
est très mauvais comparé aux fous des
blancs il va falloir trouver appris hier
de l'activer c'est ce qui va essayer de
faire et ça peut être un peu l'ambition
menace une fourchette ou g6 à air france
est recoupé la diagonale du fou
attention les d'approuver call c'est un
piège systématique c'est internet
toujours la dame vous de vous prend
achète ça c'est vraiment ça revient très
souvent ce thème dans les parties il a
trouvé le couvent siège est sis les
battements aux menaces vraiment d'impro
des 4 du coup il revient la f3 est un
peu bizarre je préfère être là gaz de 4
après avoir défendu le plombe annonce
design on arrive à jouer ces cinq
ballons aucun problème au contraire ils
ont
résolus le point principal qui était
leur mauvais vous ils menacent de
détériorer la structure des plans
secrets des bonnes cases pour leurs
cavaliers donc en grid est qui qui fait
le taf avec le noir artix garfunkel
exactement on va voir si on me les
dogues se fait là qu'est alors il
chauffe ou deux guitares un peu forcé de
faire feu ou passifs ou préserver sa
structure de pions maintenant et que les
douars va peut-être juste mettre nos
tours sur les colonnes ouverte qui
s'apprête à s'ouvrir trop d'ennemis tour
s'est vite et à brembo égaliser voire
peut-être un peu plus ici de trois ne
craint pas grande chose pour alain bergé
s'est tu y as tu te fous de cases noires
adverse pour profiter des cases noires
qu'elle éprouve des 4 on peut essayer de
harry veut doubler les tours hockey la
question maintenant c est ce qu on a
intérêt à changer notre fou couples
cavaliers avec l'idée derrière de jouer
cavalier e 5 c'était envisageable il a
préféré versant cavallero c5 qui peut y
avoir des échanges massif sur la colonne
des
et la position le cas encore une fois
très équilibré mais je suis peut-être un
petit avantage au noir une b2 parfois
qui peut être faire le fou et dans une
diagonale flactif votre cavalier sur une
case
le solide ou là très clairement il
montre avec les plans qui veut jouer b4
une très beau logique aussi est-ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas essayer de jouer le p5
ici chasser ce cavalier échanger les
toits vingt cinq ab4 quand même des spas
grammont soir mais notre cavalier comme
se fait chasser les types peut aller aux
assises pour mettre la pression sur une
baisse b4 et récupérer la case
directement océanique silva en p4 ou
faire attention des fouets 3d clouage
peut être un peu dangereux salut
l'interrupteur
alors il est venu comme ça si je pensais
la botte de séjour il fait de voir une
bonne partie stratégique en guérit tech
et cavalli c2c intéressant ni veux pas
que vous cédez la case ses sens qu'ici
avec les blondes ou qui préfèrent
défendre sur youtube et vous mais les
deux tours ont pu servir vous propose
cette simplification
alors voilà il a oublié son pion b6 qui
déforme et 4 parce que l'idée des noirs
c'était certainement d'attaqué v4 d'un
pro b 6 on se retrouve avec deux pions
passait bien avec les blancs et ça
risquerait d'être décisif or il
réfléchit barbarian peut-être
je sais pas trop à quoi d'ailleurs parce
que en dépit de la dame défendre il a
raté il a juste oublié le pion p6 donc
ici en grid ac s'en sort très bien
maintenant il peut manger b4 leïla est
un pion est finalement peut-être qu'il
est clément il aura pas mieux que
d'essayer de faire des chèques
perpétuelle sur case noire mais en
sachant qu'il ya 500 points de plus et
l'eau il ya peu de chance je vais je
suis contenté de la nul et ils préfèrent
jouer une position objectivement
inférieur plutôt que de forcer la tenue
est certainement faire la même chose à
sa place et ça lui steven lg alors la
minurcat rencontre à 20 secondes
donc c'est assurément un facteur qui a
influencé sa décision de de continuer la
partie et a toujours des thèmes faut
faire attention votre vigilant avec les
noirs là le but dès demain c'est
vraiment de être échangé au moins une
pièce simplifier la pollution par
exemple les finales juste de fou serait
très facilement gagné haut la ceni des
tipis l'on va créer deux contres jeu sur
le roi adverse et femmes de la prise
voilà c'est qu'on a quand même ouvert
sera ok maintenant il y aura toujours
des thèmes des chèques perpétuelle
peuvent traîner donc faire attention et
je sens que ça tourne un petit peu la
hongrie tonnes qui subit la pression
attention à ne pas se noyer
il fait vraiment beaucoup trop trou sur
son roi et du coup c bat parcelle d'à
peine 7 et avait fui donc c'est dommage
un effet vraiment une bonne partie les
barbarians un petit peu au métier juste
avec la poussée du pur h il a créé une
brèche et il a réussi à faire craquer
avec la bordure
en grès dac alors dans ma part gardé
sarine
[Musique]
allez on va partir sur un joueur 521
entre aix et débute donc nicolas jacquot
exc vim il ya une tour demande c'est
être pas le plus intéressant je voulais
voir un petit peu puisque je reconnais
que j'avais rarement des choix avec
ariel aussi bas mais on voit que malgré
tout de particules à el bulli l'a perdu
en tout on menace tout à la lire il ya
une belle affiche entre cette baisse des
balades vertes
on arrive en courant serait bien de
choquer une partie un petit peu au
départ et ici on a la paire de fou
contre une tour c'est toujours un combat
intéressant mais là c'est juste la
victoire pour balade verte qui a très
bien joli et d'enfilades à la femme et
gagne la tour pour le cube ont
certainement que cette baisse va
abandonner décès deux pages au rire mais
le problème c'est qu'il a seulement deux
pions pour les deux fous et les deux
fous sont trop forts il a mangé tous les
pions sans problème il arrive même pas
le pousser à devoir le battait me
prouver qu'ils semateg de fou contre un
mois on est très très loin
beaucoup de faux de pions chez réno donc
balade verte qui est chaud alors
dix grandes robes donc quand une finale
deux tours vers le tour avec trois
plombes plus certainement beaucoup trop
un quatrième là juste à avancer ses
pions et aller à dame
digigram robe on va le laisser vous
prouver sa technique et alors qu'est ce
qu'on va les voir et on avoue ne pas
avoir encore maugrée fu lei alors merci
pour le lien maugrée folle al hilal et
blanc contre digital dragon fr un jouet
un belge pouvez-vous l'oeil qui est
maître fide qu'avec les plans ici par
kwh est largement favori mais on va voir
le fichier vite cette spéciale de
l'activé comme ça dans la grande
diagonale mais depuis on assiste demeure
un peu faible pour l'instant le faux est
pas très bon ce cavalier manque de 15h
cats est pas une nouvelle option au bac
les blancs quand même beaucoup plus d
espace c'est sympa mais bon je pense que
c'est vraiment bien joué dans cette idée
de prendre un peu d'air à el al dam a
certainement dû du fouet f3 moment donné
on a du mal à trouver de casse pour ce
cavalier
alors ce serait trop long de toutes
façons de contrôler voyage une fourrière
trois salles c'est logique va jouer ou
c6
il va y avoir certainement une lutte
dans la colonne des lissiers une typique
ce sera peut-être de sacrifier une
qualité pour les blondes et 6 pour
pourquoi pas couvrir à diagonale de
notre fonction gsm
alors qu'il commence les manoeuvres de
recycler avec son cavalier pense que
tout va ce liquide et dans la colonne
des et ria du cavalier des cinq du fou
des sanctions des sacrifices très
intéressant les thématiques
moi j'aime beaucoup cavaliers des cinq
l'épée pions pas essayer sans trop
soutenu par les deux fous c'était
vraiment intéressant
la page web et comme ce qui va avoir du
mal à passer en échangeant toutes les
pièces à position noir demeure quand
même très solide c'est pas cavalier près
de 4 après fou et iii angers peine en
arrière fond f3 il y avait effectivement
quelle épreuve n 4 avait raison qui
marchait un oubli des 2 juin même si
ouvrir la colonelle sorek réclament des
compensations pour les blancs alors pour
l'instant d'un raté du coup finalement
il a joué le sacrifice de pièces que
j'ai évoqués mais la différence et qui
l'avait plongée l'info moi je préférais
quand même avec les avec le foot est
blanche entre avant un fou adverse qui
aurait été en difficulté ici je suis
moins certains de la prestation de
sacrifice même si leur pratique c'est
gilles parce que les pièces noires
sokhon très facile mais pour l'instant
on attaque des six plein de fois dont
n'empêche le 6 donc les morts équipage a
eu 6 ils seront pagaille alors là il
faut prendre des six comprend des six en
fait ça me permettait d'ailleurs il ya
eu une finale depuis leur ai juste perdu
son groupe de six
la bataille va être impératif de ramener
le roi a tout fait pour contrôler la
case de 6 ou qu'on va marquer de temps
on ici il a reperdu la pièce en plus ça
va juste gagné très facilement il allie
la même pas essayé d'empêcher le 6 donc
là je pense tu peux abandonner
maintenant mon réflexe fait un petit peu
peur je pense même si on pratique nos
sacrifices et d'efforts digital a raté 2
3 2 3 occasions tactique de faire mal à
son adversaire
alors trouvé notre parti a d'autres où
une particuliers commencent un petit peu
pour l'instant en tête on a balade verte
et mauvais fowler et on a caché le droit
puisque kevin n'est pas là on va lui
rendre un petit hommage à travers
l'ancien logo vitrine lequel je le crois
qu'ils avaient blanc contre et contre
est lié et j'ai l'impression que ça se
passe pas très bien pour quelqu'un qui
avait le droit de perdre beaucoup
beaucoup de pièces alors il a encore un
semblant d'attac
mais les noirs menace de simplifier la
position avec force il manque deux tours
déjà et surtout au moins six thèmes
pions j'ai pas ce qui s'est passé auquel
j'ai le droit
alors ils misent peut-être tout sur un
compte du besoin d'art table que quatre
secondes mais normalement c'est une
position assez ça il a juste à faire
participer ses tours par exemple huit
tours détroit ça c'est très bien aussi
la graine 5 tourne plus une tour et une
qualité c'est beaucoup quel j'ai le
droit qui se bat quand même il est c'est
de créer des réseaux de dare dare sur
cases noires mais la dame des fonds très
bien et c'est la position des noirs et
c'est très bien joué il fait une
enfilade sur la quatrième en auge m il
va encore essayer de faire un échec à
lever encore une fois c'est de l'eau
pour le coup très artificielle mais par
contre a plus qu'une seconde la faillite
bear 6
manger des pièces alors le four à
reculer le projet kde par exemple mais
je veux quand même avec moins d'une
seconde ces couacs au prix y est donc
c'est pas ce rassurant
je crains qu'il ne paraît il est tombé
c'est assez terrible ça c'est terrible
de perdre autant cette partie d'un plus
juste plus manger lecavalier et ryan
avait fallait pas chercher pas chercher
compliqué il avait juste 1000 1000
pièces de plus mais bon qu'est la droite
gagner autant c'était quand même
particulier un bon salle 1
on va retourner voir banane verte contre
feel you tube a diverti en finale deux
tours et la pj dans tourbe évite juste
qu'ils gagnent note qu'ils fassent un
petit peu attention de ne pas s'allier
mais ça devrait pas lui poser de
problème donc moi que souvent le jour
avec plus de canaux à beaucoup plus de
temps que l'adversaire décide de jouer
très vite pour faire le plus de parties
possible de marquer le plus de points de
vue c'est un petit peu la course c'est à
chaque fois un course au bond et donc
voilà de nouveau en danger par balade
verte
vous savez quoi place bombail verte qui
seul en tête avec six sur six est
derrière d'amour et fall a ému et le
crush ue allait poursuivre en attendant
dieu alors justement celle de baisse
outre mme au greffe au live n'est pas
trop trop beaux dans la partie la
position là assez intéressant qui a un
peu plus pour les blancs qui ont plus du
jeu sur la colonne h salle cepej
impressions des jeux regarder de ces
partis il a des pièces doublé dans la
colonne h salut le chien l'eau pour
l'instant c'est bien défendu mais on
voit ce duo de cavaliers qui est quand
même extrêmement fort très
complémentaires ils se défendent
l'un l'autre et du coup ben allez les
blancs comment votre avantage ici le fou
il pourra peut-être trouvé un peu de jeu
dans cette diagonale mais il restera
beaucoup moins efficace que ce qu'à
l'avenir on le 4 qui est même très
solidement ancré dans la position leurs
battements ils ont certainement 7 jeux à
je suis à bien tout racisme voilà bien
joué ce que b si c'était vraiment
bizarre on va dire à techniquement parce
que créer une brousse faiblesse
il suffit juste de doubler tour surtout
à vii ont droit à un tour pro v6 pour
profiter du clonage
vous voyez un deuxième pion dans une
tour en plus qui va rentrer et on a un
cavalier dominant ça fait beaucoup de
petits plus qui au final a dit younès
transformer davantage décisif est mort
et collèges pour ça c'est la population
et la banda ne veut pas perdre de temps
dans une partie futur il veut essayer de
se rattraper tout de suite
alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme partir en
cours pierre pas de chance la partie
d'en déterminer
de joie dans des lots très proche
tomawak contre 19 90 alors que donne
cette position il ya égalité matérielle
et blanc viennent d'attaquer la tour b 5
latéraux composé d'eau pourrait
peut-être quand même assisté à une
partie d'attac
si si si c'est l'art c'est logique ou
fou 17
le problème de fou 17 et qui va y avoir
du canadien des cinq à rebours est donc
ces sites est vraiment très important
pour prendre la case des s'inquiète pas
ceux à se prendre un cavalier des cinq
cavaliers problème si c'est le roi henry
aurait pris cher à priori maintenant ses
pions des six qui est un peu fermé le
juge veut pousser cette pour le défendre
le principal problème des noirs c'est
comme se clôt à vous de voir réussir à
s'en dépêtrer
un bourg donner des coups simples
centralisateur paraissent assez bien
pour les bleus ici et noir ils peuvent
quant à elles menaçaient de trouver du
crochet assez vite avec b 5 à 5 à 4 à 5
atempo donc réfléchi 10 10 pour
finalement le jouet est ici on vous
prend bel 5 peut être une idée il faut
qu'il y ait des cinq derrière mais
c'était quand même risqué liens préférés
recyclés par la caste f1 normalement
possible p 4 ce cavalier manque de
bonnes cases il va certainement aller
aura 4 et joue un rôle de bloqueur
contre l'attack les barques ou ce qui
sera hors jeu roi quatre espions le cac
se retrouvera faible
été joués veut pas d'autres casques
cavalli l'a46 nord ont eux deux ils
ajustent perdre le pion
vous êtes sages c'est le week end les
gens sortent peut-être de chasseurs
brave les interdits
c'est pas alors il a toujours à jouer au
hockey
assez étonnant ici beaucoup semblent le
plus tôt force elle alors il est venu en
e2 de il ya juste tout reprendre 1,4 à
priori suis pas quel est son idée est
très bizarre cavaliers de la part de
thomas wac et je sais pas qu'est le
drapeau à leucate en plus ça a très peu
fou ça défend b4 ce fouillis nous embête
énormément avec le clouage combat est
juste gagner un trou central en plus
gagnon des tempos sur les pièces adverse
donc c'est vraiment tout bénef pour les
noirs ici alors la donne la paire de fou
c'est quand même plusieurs décisions
très douteuse je pense de la part de
deux thomas wac les si on peut
simplement échanger les tours je vais
des cinq ne tourne plus la perdre ou
font un très gros avantage additionnel
alors deux sens que c'est bien de jouer
maintenant avec les blancs en fait on
n'a plus aucune attaque tour est vite
c'est très artificielle en fait la boue
il va faire un échec ok d'accord c'est
pas très grave l'ouvragé si ça on n'a
aucun problème est abandonnée au prince
où paissaient depuis pour chasser cette
tour de la huitième en rocher et à terme
va essayer de jouer c'est ça ou chasser
ce cavalier alors dames promet gadget
pas vu inception qui a été oublié
peut-être par les noix est en moi du
coup il ya dame bref 2 quelles recettes
versées tactique vous fout des trois
paraîtrait logique chaque intermédiaire
maintenant j'ai bien peur arriver dans
ta belle fuite des fuites masse et c'est
le craquage vous finalement même si
elles tous bien joué avec les noix dès
que la pulsion c'est un peu actif y est
il a craqué l'alma devait être
apparemment h 8 aura pas de perpétuels
roi peut s'échapper au c3 attention sur
canal 2 il ya peut-être au f4 qui va
donner à des gens qui perpétuent village
loi c-36 est là juste là perdu en prison
et le problème en fait ici c'est que
[Musique]
parfois on peut ne pas le voir là c'est
le coup fourré c'est la condamnation
prend pas la dame à la force des choses
des fois il pas beaucoup de temps avait
pas attention mais leur emprise sur
échec là n'est obligé du coup c'est la
bombe ou alors c'est de trouver une
autre partie
un paquito paquito hongrie dunk
je vous confie qu'au début quand même
pouvoir et doyle baser plus tard il a
joint black bar lounge facile par la
partie
réputé un peu comme une réfutation
donc il n'a pas sorti son fonds 25 miles
au fond pas si les blancs l'attaquent en
j'annonce un peu au la position actuelle
et ongle high-tech c'est vraiment le
tout pour le tout c'est à dire qui
l'abandonnent complètement surréel table
pour essayer de monter une attaque le
pape c'est assez solide on est dans
cette position il c'est pour faire mais
son cas est alors j'ai pas pourquoi ils
étaient faire c'est celle qu'on veut 7
parce que du coup le gardien perdu mais
s'il l'est malheureusement son black
barrette perdre il n'y a pas de là il
peut se dire le continent jeu recettes
on pourra faire d'un projet c'est
d'essayer de poser des problèmes sauf
que dans l'absolu la cie les malins avec
les normes du jouet tours 8
lui dire tout cavalier ma nulle part où
je ne mangeait tranquillement avec la
tour là il est ce un coup de coupe roger
en pratique il ya toujours une place de
plus mais débat nécessaire
alors le petit chien qui affronte capsié
le droit va voir après cette partie si
je la trouve il ya quelques échappées
madame m6 et safe
il veut essayer de repartir de l'autre
côté c'est assez mal un bémol c'est que
cette fois au sol il tient normalement
il a une pièce de mort mais voilà tu
amènes très bien pour couvrir tous les
échecs
une sélection qui commencent à avancer
ressent du coup je crois que le canard
va devoir bewkes bas un petit peu
abandonné sous peu mais se bat d'abuja à
là-bas le choix est vraiment à tout prix
changer les dames est clos à chaque coup
ils essaient de forcer des changes mais
on pourrait juste avancer ses pions en
fait on l'a peu 3 dans la ja d'apprendre
en parle
il vient de revenir et cas d'aveux 5 par
exemple pour parler de trois tombes et
les six f4 ya l'embarras du choix pâques
et aux envois eu six c'est un coup je
n'aurais pas joué mais c'est un coup
bien sûr il ya une idée c'est de créer
ce vis-à-vis de ceux des clous et c'est
en soi sa peine du tout gala un petit
peu je trouve avec sa pièce de 100 merci
à jonathan le nombre d'échecs qu'a pu
faire les blancs à écouter nos jeux d
échecs ils sont très largement devant
mais mon problème c'est que ces deux
échecs pour faire un chagrin il sacrifie
sa dame je sais pas ce qu'il a vu en
grès jack mais c'est certainement trompé
du coup le temps de rendre les armes
alors qu'est ce qu'on va pêcher un
jambon-beurre
c'est un petit peu soit il est 13 heures
55 sont encore l'or du charbon beurre
pour moi un jambon-beurre cas les noirs
contre oscar in la caravelle alors on a
une joueuse en plus là si fréquent la
position a l'air plutôt intéressant elle
vient de faire un échec lors duquel m je
suppose j'espère labérou question son
adversaire et jambon beurre du coup qui
se retrouvent explorant en 17 et pas
cette bonne nouvelle a priori pas il
aura toujours comme thème de sacrifier
son cavalier pour récupérer l'autre ça
peut quand même être très dangereux si
certainement la solution calais 3 5 km
épreuve 5
on reprendra du roi il est ainsi
probable bien sûr et une fonction
attention là comme un roi petit peu
arrogants russie rodez 6 mais c'est pas
si facile de l'exploiter et au final il
a grillé un pion dans la sphère alors là
c'est courageux de la part d' oscar in
de sacrifier les cavaliers et décide
d'ouvrir les lignes au maximum
malheureusement je pense que objetivo ça
n'a pas marché
il manquera un petit peu de matériel
mais au caire les rois sont plus les
noirs sont pas à l'abri de ce qu'on fait
ici laisse par la terre alors par
exemple 4 bat voilà en plein dedans tout
reprend 24 riscal valoir à ce qu'apple
non c'est dommage elle pouvait récupérer
sa pièce avec intérêt et maintenant
qu'elle et ses 300 bongo donc argent du
beurre qui s'est bien rattrapé et du
coup il va voir sa pièce de plus et son
roi en plein centre sera relativement à
l'abri si c'est une partie intéressante
aux oscars et de gaieté à s'écrase
s'il veut ne parlons même pas payer
malheureusement le sandwich et rouge ils
sont juste 3,17 ensuite on va devoir se
cacher avec son roi et le cavalier est
trop fort tout simplement est bien
protégé qui couvre tous les problèmes de
noir
alors qu'est ce qui t'arrive particules
ici le monde prennent un petit temps de
réflexion aux finalement sentent que
leur chance est passée est abandonné on
peut que saluer ce choix et s'est trouvé
une nouvelle partie la route est je
regarde juste un petit peu le classement
c'est toujours balade verte qui mène la
danse avec neuf sur des faits oui les
crèches ou est pas loin derrière avec 8
sur 8 mai will rock you je trouve que
jamais je vois bien regarder deux de ces
partis mais niveau timing à chaque fois
n'est pas très beau du coup tant pis on
va partir sur jj alors donc qu'une
finale de foot couleurs opposées la jci
contre coutier color vous et quatre
contre quatre
avec un peu de chance vous pourrez finir
le stream là-dessus à dire que la partie
ne pourrait bien durer une heure avec le
zinc renmans les deux joueurs ne veulent
pas faire bulle parce qu'ici à priori
peut jouer à l'infini en fait des coûts
d'attendre des deux côtés typiquement
les vous proposez vraiment favoris cela
nul du coup co kg fascinant entendu mais
en tout cas si c'est le cas c'est à
cette adresse mon adversaire accepta nul
on va pas subir cette finale trop
longtemps
j'ai le droit contre culture mais j'ai
l'impression que leur parti a commencé
cette 79ème coup et ça lui renault et
merci à toi alors on a une finale deux
tours che nul massive a décidemment la
manche n ya nul n'en sait pas si
fréquent à ses cadences
on va essayer de prouver une partie à un
petit peu plus au début c'est le cas
avec barbarian par marianne qui est
souvent très chaud dans nos arènes et
qui a les blancs contre qui est en cause
les mater je sais pas si leur amour
espagnol mais je vais prononcer ça comme
ça et ici on qu'il vient de paris n'a
pas de la descente il ya la tension au
centre depuis un petit moment ils 22 h 3
est tout ouïe à la colonelle cas ça
assez intéressante pour les plans j'aime
bien les blancs cette position surtout
maintenant ils peuvent ouvrir leur se
chauffe eau et en fait leur jeu mettra
ses versions distinctes toutes les
pièces qu'ils regardent un petit peu par
le roi adverse et la peine était il a
pris la qualité à tembo s'est assis le
beau jeu et c'est très bien gré parce
que ce roi il se retrouve dépourvu de
défenseurs les cavaliers ainsi cité la
seule pièce qu'ils protégeaient leur one
par maintenant f5 été forcé par les
maths mais il peut mater tranquillement
sur 15 noir il va jouer d'un même six
fois çi s'il y aura matin par a plongé
cette barbarians qui nous avait une
petite démonstration à vous pouvez le
retenir ce sacrifice de qualité aux ifsi
si les thématiques des l'instant on
parvient à ouvrir leur calvaire
c'est souvent fatale lors actuellement
il est très cher leur retard de
développement et le matin et un pas
rallonger cette donc un temps pour une
charge nouvelle fuite et prendre un
petit peu donc dans marianne du cou qui
marque les points on va basculer sur une
partie alors mais une position qu'elle a
assez chaude entre thomass 1515 et
d'orgue avec as roi baladeur il ya
encore une fois est une pièce de plus
cela j'ai cru qu'il y avait une qualité
pour la pièce mais non il faut essayer
de trouver le mat ce roi dans les
courants d'air
il ya beaucoup de cases noires ou
devrait certainement avoir un schéma de
bahts
est-ce qu'on commencerait pas par deux
dames c'est un exemple bref si ce
bouquet leroy peut-être essayer de se se
cacher parce que les noirs ils espèrent
un petit peu robe de conte projet avec
leurs pions on se doit est insuffisant
ce fou il manque de bonnes cases comme
s'il berçait 3 juste pour perdre de
temps après on peut se permettre de
jouer au foot et deux qui décident de
garder son cavalier or foucher le simple
par exemple pour défendre la tour à tour
peut aussi un peu ont reculé vers
davillars un terrain vague quelques
qu'auparavant avec les blancs sa valeur
quand même très suspect et l'a pas trop
le choix
je vais vite dans ces cas-là si la pub
15 secondes il va réfléchir sacrifier
mais il veut aussi se compliquer la vie
on a un gros avantage comme ça matériel
ça sert à rien de laisser une chance à
notre adverse
je le fous et se dirige vers la très
belle kazan des 5000 sera pas
délogeables il protège la rupture il
attaquera nadal on se doit juste à
réussir à ramener cette date vers le roi
d'une façon ou d'une autre on
m'interroge pas pris la peine le fou des
cinq ici c'est quand même plus simple la
taxe 5 a dû s'en soucier
pas reculer donc le principal la
principale pic de dépenses certainement
de chez elle la pendule parce que sinon
c'est vraiment écrasants dcl options et
cinq tombes le diagonal doit s'ouvrir et
là le fou le fou qui manque cruellement
noir va se faire sentir d'autant plus
nos trois écrans rien il sera très à
l'abri jour h2s est un as à perdre ville
de gagner un peu de temps et c'est un
coup préventif pas hésité à de change
d'optique ou quand vous êtes en
difficulté au temps et là il réfléchit
beaucoup trop par exemple son adversaire
de menaces rien n'y a aucun danger
pourrait passer notre tou avec les
blancs trois quatre fois de suite nous
arrive derrière donc dans ces cas-là
faut vraiment le seul danger c'est de se
mettre trop bas à la pendule est ce que
les droits et qu'une collation
donc faut qu'ils enclenchent trop bas ou
pas se faire peur inutilement
voici très bien la pensée le pion way de
manger la tour dans qui continue
certainement à cause du temps même s'ils
vivent ici avec un agrément c'est
largement suffisant ou match au delà
d'une façon ou d'une autre
et voilà ça fait le boulot et on devrait
avoir un abandon d'ici quelques secondes
[Musique]
on sent j'ai commencé à chercher mon
parti je me jusqu'au battre quatre
habitants n'ont pas regardé oui oui le
crush on n'a pas beaucoup vu opus c'est
bien on commence du début et il a fait
face un chapiteau avec les douars aspect
très intéressant je te moyenne un grand
grand écart et l'eau voir comment il
gère ça le oui les crèches ou pour
essayer de gagner le plus possible et
j'ai oct
s'il parvient à poser des problèmes à
son adversaire
on voit la première action dès demain
c'était dur et qu'on se fout
de créer cette structure il a décidé pas
développer ces pièces mais j'ai assez
sceptique quand même alors faut il ya
peut-être que mon le facteur lots qui
joue ici au caire je suis plus fort je
peux juste envoyer très vite pour
marquer des points dans mon objectif je
profite un peu ambitieux arrachant
qu'immédiatement sens développé du tout
parce qu'avec les blancs en fait l'idée
serait de casser évidemment ce centre
pour faire revivre ce fou le plus vite
possible mais trois poupées 2 d'un petit
peu long à détroit c'est bien joué déjà
eu des petits problèmes je trouve pour
les noirs ici la petite joy calcin il a
pris de la prix de f1 ça c'est
assurément une assez grosse erreur de la
part des blancs d'où vient cette des
godasses add-on hot n cold war on va les
agents et maintenant cette fois là je
vais être très dangereuses et là avec
son poing coups comme d'hab' g5 juste
pour créer une doublette sur la
colonnade risque d'être problématique
je vois pas comment on arrive à défendre
à h 2 en fait elles seront bien que le
h3c g3 qui se retrouvera très faible je
donne pas cher de la peau de jacques oct
notre position
ses allures de no bail out pour ce qui
est de l'entraînement il n'hésite pas à
m'envoyer un message en privé sinon ça
se passe par sky ou je te partage mon
écran on discute ensemble bien sûr de
déjà de doute on est de ton parcours de
tes envies de ce que tes objectifs
et puis ensuite une fois que j'ai pu un
peu évaluées ton niveau on peut mettre
en place un travail à moyen terme
ensemble ou terme même mais n'hésite pas
à m'envoyer un message sur mon compte
chez ce cas c'est le même pseudo robin
syl d'ici là bas notre ami willy
cruciaux qui galèrent un petit peu j'ai
pas trop compris pourquoi il n'avait pas
directement mais sa nomination pour
menacer à tours l2 et puis je veux grand
reng qu'ici ou tout début il avait un
grand retard de développement et
finalement on se rend compte que les
plans sait pas trop ce qu'ils ont joué
c'est là on peut aussi s'en tira
différence de niveau c'est un petit peu
il mange des pions mais le problème
c'est que ici
la priorité c'est loin oui j'ai posé
cheikh mon jour bien sûr pour mater le
roi ils mentent gm cède très très très
ambitieux et les buts et tactiquement
simplement un homme au delà de ça je
veux pas se permettre de jouer laissant
à moitié de nos pièces à ya un problème
de yaya toure des indes arrière qui
arrive suivi de alors il l'a pas vu tour
des rtt connu plus fort mais là c'est
très joli finalement maniax était aussi
fort et il ya pas de force et courage de
donc une partie quand même très proche
de will cruciaux qui a gagné avec style
en étant très agressif avec les noirs
qui fait qu'au classement
il talonne aux mains du home alain
dewerdt barbarian qui ont tous les 2 37
points avec 10 sur 11
cf il reste une grosse demi-heure pour
les départager à une partie entre une
finale finale de cavaliers on va
regarder ce que ça d'autres mots great
falls et alex et ré tard avec un trio
riz lait blanc dans la tourmente je ne
m'abuse
mais après devient le cannabis et je
pense les plus compliqués à calculer
alors je pense qu'il va s'en sortir
en fait mme sirois des quatre y aura
toujours du cavalier g5 il devrait s'en
sortir et si les blues ont secoué par la
finale objectivement cette belle
difficile va même l'a gagnée puisque
jure qu'elle est lui aussi séquelles et
j'ai cinq boucles a justement un gros
oubli tactique mais en fait j'ai pas
regardé les pendules il avait 2 minutes
30 à 5 secondes
donc c'est juste ça s'est joué là dessus
parce que c'était les noirs qui devait
qu'il devait jouer le grand merci à
simon bah nappe à tata junior la reine
s'appelle court arena
je file le lire comme d'habitude en fait
on y voyait chaoui finale de guerrier
c'est vraiment les plus durs à calculer
parce qu'autant les finales de
production des pièces à grande portée
dans une vision d'ensemble plus simple
donc à la liez vous qualifier tous les
sauts c'est facile dans vos clients
alors j'aimerais bien trouver bananes
vertes ou ou barbarian qui sont en tête
alors la banane verte qui est va
commencer une partie avec les doigts
outre bidouille douik a pas l'appareil
m'ont le plus facile de la reine pour
lui avec la petite madleen stream mais
il va devoir réaliser l'exploit
maintenant on a l'habitude de la
scandinave de bananes vertes
c'est devenu un classique et il joue la
variante est que detroit je ne connais
pas qui mais a l'air à première vue rend
plus facile pour les blancs oui s'il
doit juste juste échangé par une pièce
directement à cet hommage
c'est dommage pour bidouiller de perdre
une pièce si vite dans l'ouverture
quelque chose sûrement à sa portée quand
même ils auraient pu calculer ça et du
coup banane verte
autant dire que si tout est très très
vite
pour accentuer son avance je crois qu'il
a pris la tête de vérifier sur sur
barbaria loi il a deux petits points
d'avance et peut-être marqué un point
très vite
si à d'autres partis en même temps quand
même suivre celle ci jusqu'au bout pour
voir si barbarian balade verte pardon se
montre efficace
hk sa part est un peu bizarre 7h04 jouer
trois sets plus solides bidouille juste
et pas il cède pas non plus l'habitude
je mets beaucoup à cette cadence
5 ça va assez vite à l'étroit en plus
doux et surtout d'affronter des joueurs
aussi forts
ça peut aussi mettre la pression des
fois quand vous jouez contre un joueur
supposément bien mieux classés que vous
alors qu'elle est prouvée 4c répondu à
tempo c'est bien de jouer simplement il
va récupérer le fou à la fin de la
variante donc il aura au passage en gros
j'ai deux petits pions donc pour
l'instant il est très efficace et si oui
à reculer ce monde fou c'était
certainement le mieux à faire est et
céderont hockey est bon objectivement
objectivement c'est complètement
gagnerons est-ce qu'on a une autre
partie parce que là on n'a pas vraiment
de doutes sur la victoire à venir de
bananes vertes du coup il ya un duel de
poids lourds dhr maugrée fallen et
cryptes al dah belle brochette de pions
pour la pièce c'est jolie recette de
serpents d'options serpentins et
obstacles joly c'est surtout très fort
bien supérieure à ce malheureux fou donc
il se devrait gagner un autre problème
pour les blancs disent entre eux
problème c'est plus facile chaque
attaque du genre deux minutes donc la
cave un peu le temps
voilà ici fischer commencent à organiser
lé là en fait très intense pour le
risque est que si rien ne se passe et
les douars parliez d'un robe le fou pour
trois pions parce que maintenant le
problème c'est que le pion détourne
aussi alors passage avait pas pensé mais
à tour processes tout simplement donc
finalement il va s'en sortir par là nul
parce qu'il n'a pas été très vigilants à
l'excellent fallait à tout prix empêcher
le sacrifice sur sur les gens et peut
encore un petit peu pressés mais parce
que leurs ouailles du côté suisse hier
peut couper les deux pions sur isolé
mais objectivement ça va être ne
s'allume et le kitsch
tél ça arrive les aida il ya des bons
jours et des mauvais jours alors il l'a
envoyé la bonne de franceschi criminal
justice avec son droit et le deux contre
un normalement on n'est pas suffisant il
proposait de nominations sont adversa ya
aucune raison d'accepter ici de ce
qu'eric les blancs car on perd c'est
quand même de mettre la pression
s'échapper aberration ça se gagne
ce genre de truc de position mais avec
une pâte défense sud attendent en fait
pour les noirs doit 3 est protégé par le
pion des échecs latéraux donc juste on
attend et de tours elle aura pour
mission de couper le roi adverse de le
harceler
ça c'est bien joué que s'ils protègent à
7 et manger maintenant il va juste
attendre et que des coups d'attentes sur
la septième manche
elles et ils raviveront m5 ça change
rien
moi j'aurais continué d'attendre ici
mais bon ça doit perdre nul à l'idée
c'est juste de couvrir les échecs on va
en fait il tourne en rond bref voilà un
moment donné des bras jouer g5 et je les
respecte les options h et du coup ce
sera nulle en hachis céda la m5 et 5
tout simplement aux joutes sur le
clouage et maintenant celle l'annulant
il peut jouer tour g7
quel que soit le choix des moments ici
juste échec perpétuelle je trouve
mettre la pâte rejouer et du coup une
nul finalement logique était assez
intéressante donc souhaité par la finale
b volaille avec ses marraines qui ont
ils auraient pu gagner
qui reste quand même encore du temps
donc rien n'est joué entre autres
balades vertes wilks rechou et barbarian
les trois sont dans un mouchoir de poche
ce que je trouve est noté 3 j'ai vu
barbarian ouais tiens les blancs contre
auquel les noirs contre feel you tube
vient de se faire attaquer barbarian sur
la colonne h le problème principal baron
section fou il est pas trop mais
peut-être qu'il peut trouver un petit
peu d'avenir sur une autre dira goda
pourquoi pas sacrifiant pour meurent
laquelle lâché b2 je pense que barbarian
procuste l'initiative ici et qu'un tour
qui rentreront le palier qui va venir
s'activer trouver des bonnes cases et le
problème c'est que ces pièces blanches
ici être complètement hors jeu
c'est le danger souvent quand vous
entamez une attaque sur les droits
l'équipe être passée au tour comme ça
c'est qu'ensuite les pièces se retrouve
complètement en jeu le même elle empêche
les blancs d'inscrire un échappatoire
pour le roy on puisque oublier sa tour
au passage à vide avant ça n'aide pas et
du coup le mcs va suivre certainement
rapidement parce que le score est blond
il vous jamais le temps d'attaquer c'est
quand même pas de dames frangine 6 pour
achever ce que le roi s'échapper et du
coup ils profitent de la faiblesse de la
première embauche elle pour asséner un
match du groupe a à la fin at il raté
battant d'un on sera mal que peut pas
traiter mais peut-être justement j'ai
une tour pour le plaisir au passage
donc ils recollent et la course
suite continue on va voir si wilko xiu
xiu contre culture ça c'est une partie
prometteuse will rock you had ou aigle
noir
alors on a joué tous solides cette fois
ci je pense que s'il s'adapte un peu au
niveau de son adversaire
belle rose pâle et h5 à tour de bras
d'un développement à ses standards des
deux côtés ça devrait se terminer par
double petit rock c'est la limite
pression ou va certainement jouer tams
et deux pour défendre le cavalier est
attaqué une seconde fois lequel à lyon
de 4 alors f5 et hippiques aussi vous
consolider la position de notre
valeureux destrier en 1/4 et avec les
blancs d'un petit peu de mal à faire la
leçon et rien de chasser on me pose la
question soit on décide de reculer ou
c'est le bon soir puisqu'on a quand même
une belle diagonale ici à venir
tranquillement 6 7
les brûleurs je vais être à l'el dames
et les douars peut pas balancer du g5 g4
et essayer de prendre un avantage elle
raconte tandis que les blues jouent à
quelle date et le petit rock serait très
très drôle de voir sur ce dernier point
le plan n'a pas été jouer c'est moi qui
déjeunaient panne c'est quoi vos rides
est pas favorable
donc ici la position doit à l'air très
bonne et en plus maintenant je pense que
prendre une ktm grosse erreur at
recouvrir la colonne f c'est la très
très dangereux notre fou au bout de bois
ici les voir des terres et 3 2
des fous chez 3d d'amour angers de
tactique dans tous les sens je pense que
oui le crush missiles en grand danger
et s'il fait le petit rock sont rois
sera dépourvue de défenseurs et il
arrive patte avant droite à cause du
poids de leur il peut jouer un coup
comme on rompt avec 2 avec tours f1
d'abord mais il aura toujours à 3 m soit
3 soit les doivent redoubler leur tour
on écouterait passé comme cavalier des
rebelles n'ont pas trop de solution pour
s'en sortir ma peinture est ce qu'ils
m'écoutent je peux même pas d'aidé ici
c'est difficile vous pouvez le est
vraiment trop or des débats
wise est juste super super la dame tout
de suite a fallu six de commencer par
cavalier d1 mais dans tous les cas je
pense que l'abolition des très très
compliqué du coup où il crache son qui
colle aux basques des bananes vertes des
deux joueurs 46 points c'est extrêmement
serrée dans le sèche cheveux qui a les
droits
j'aime beaucoup le pseudo du couvent à
suivre contre dahang qu'on a déjà vu à
l'oeuvre sont arrivés pile au début mais
plutôt bien
merci edwards là j'essaie de varier un
petit peu le niveau des partis pour les
explications alors ici les blancs leur
avantage principal c'est l'espace dont
ce type d'ouverture et non encore un
problème avec le fou s'est vite je passe
bernard que c'est souvent une issue de
trouver un moyen de faire jouer cette
pièce avec les droits un thème un peu
récurrent dans les parties condamnés
suivis aucun des plans c'est de jouer b5
sauf que les blancs et comment lutter
pour empêcher b5 et une autre idée pour
les noirs c'est de jouer
6 ou alors est ce dans tous les cas ça
passe très souvent par une avancée de
pions pour casser le central bercy en
tout cas déstabiliser la structure de
pions adverse alors qu'avait lieu saint
le problème c'est que circonvenu fausse
qu'il avait un conte date prévue et
oublier ce qu'ils avaient choisi ce
qu'était en l'air et du coup il est
obligé de faire cette concession de
prendre avec option d et du coup de
boucher à la gueule de son faux je pense
que c'est juste un oubli tactique de la
barre des noirs et maintenant le
problème c'est que le pion c5 un petit
peu faibles ils sont tous x va avoir du
mal à jouer mais ça reste pas car là il
ya elle semble qu'elle est très tentant
g 3g pas trop au prix g3
on peut supposer que c'est pour jouer à
4 sauf peut être quatre qu'est ce que ça
fait c'est un libère le foie de mars où
quelque 4 c'est pas le plan nous coûte
g3 au moins ne fait pas grand sens
n'appartient pas la position
le choix de plans des blancs de laisser
dubitatifs les noirs et vous réussir à
trouver 5 pts elle semble plus tard et
voilà il est quand même un petit oubli
sur le plomb c'est ça attention les les
noirs ont réussi à s'active un petit peu
mais c'est dommage en fait à chaque coup
et ça c'est vraiment
[Musique]
d je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de sens
dans cette position mais a priori qui
n'a pas l'air d'être très envisagée par
par le sèche cheveux
alors on va pas que la structure de
pions des des noirs est assez inférieur
il finit par le f4 qui pour moi est
vraiment l'une des rares simplement nous
libère cette pièce qui était emmurée par
son propre option alors bien sûr il veut
essayer de rajouter une couche tard est
avec ici dans cette position les les
noirs aient pu jouer par exemple le 6
voici deux cas c'est de tendre un
élément si on arrive à oussouye 17
chaînes ça va finalement bien tourné
pour les blancs mais c'est noir avait
été précis normalement il aurait pu
éviter justement de se retrouver face à
ce mur après vous servant ainsi de jouer
m6 a abandonné donc je dirais qu'il ya
rien de faire encore même si on sent ici
que les blancs sont aux commandes
dans cette position m6 est la seule idée
remercions pas m6 on va mourir lentement
eric par exemple et les blancs ils vont
améliorer leurs pièces alors moi il fait
10 pour un style touche à rien un poil
qui arrive aussi dans ces parties c'est
juste que nous avons gelé se regardant
sur créances en attendant qu un des deux
avant centres en disant peut-être que ça
va aider
l'adversaire de jouer des six sur le
système hormonal faut donc un instant on
prend son temps mais quand même voix la
différence entre les deux rois au final
je vous rappelle que le roi cette pièce
à part entière
on craint pas de se faire 21 autres
journaux position il n'y a pas de réseau
de maths
le fait d'avoir un roi qui soutient qui
participent à l'action
ben c'est un avantage non négligeable
donc la raison d'ordre de partir à
l'abordage accents vraiment sa force ici
ses pions sont trop et là je pense que
c'est plutôt très bien joué de sa part
il recycler son cavalier le diriger vers
la 4g saint isle à 6.7 qui pouvaient une
faiblesse son cavalier il faisait rien
aux deux donc c'est une question vous
devez vous poser dans vos parties aussi
sait trouver les bonnes cartes pour vos
pièces même ça prend plusieurs coups qui
a des chemins disponible n'hésitez pas
vous raisonnez la façon suivante si vous
pouvez téléporter de pièces n'importe où
sur l'échiquier où je le ferai et
ensuite à vous de trouver un chemin de
voir si c'est réalisable
et si vous avez le temps de le faire
bien sûr encore plein de questions à se
poser derrière mais c'est un bon moyen
de trouver les bonnes cases alors elle
sent que j'aime pas du tout parce qu'il
renonce à jouer f6 has had ouvrir son
fou un jour donc il ya un côté
enterrement là c'est celui-là nouvelle
fois il est condamné un préau à gré que
les blancs même si on a un très bon
avantage positionnelle sa demande encore
du travail de la précision et de
comprendre un peu l'enjeu de la position
ici à un moment donné il faudra qu'ils
jouent des six donc je pense que met
uniquement sur la colonne des sera très
bien parce que d'être ici c'est que
soient les noirs agiront en ferme au
lndd carmack
et protéger en dc sera monstrueux et là
je réussisse ça reste bien pour lui mais
certaines cases mais je pense que
c'était quand même positionnement parce
qu'ils avaient de mieux que le fou va
revivre à faire sur mon bébé ans
également il propre la tour
lyall fou g7 et manon sais pas si clair
en fait dès le début de joie il y aura
un petit peu
l'enjeu principal c'est de jouer contre
ce fou il a pris on descend on peut
manger g6 ce roi il a pas peur il n'y a
pas de maths à l'oreille menace pas
grand chose finalement
y'a pas de mal juste fou g7 il en train
de craquer avec les blancs le
sèche-cheveux est en train de retourner
son adversaire et bad on se fout vous
allez pouvoir assister à sa résurrection
est à dire qu il va se placer aux dégâts
il sera protégé par le pion bloquera la
tour adverse et les noirs se
retrouveront au mieux dépassé d'un fou
complètement viré à un fourbe longueur
de l'échiquier qui contrôle toutes les
diagonales n'est pas pressé il peut
jouer à tout bout des quatre mais pour
des raisons obscures ne joue pas alors
il y avait
pour ses seins qui marche beaucoup
d'allant tactique pour france et 5 et
sirops apprend on récupère et derrière
l'autre tour ça permettait de gagner le
tour c'est mon fils à la bavure voulait
de genre de concept sous pression autant
bécade c'est bien joué ou doublé tour et
on résoudre nos problèmes et du coup ne
tourne plus avec les noirs le calibre
était le maître angers cinq laiteries
décoratifs de dire que pour traitement
si une bécasse
il sert six mois rien n'y a pas droit à
cibler ce que dit essaie de défendre le
pion aux six est ici bardet doit
normalement s'il faut prendre un petit
peu de justesse pour l emporter
ils ont 200 points de man ne serait une
belle performance de ses cheveux la
moyenne 3,4 il pourra juste faut être 6
tranquillement ou des présomptions
assad un déchet qui sert à rien il va
les manger g3 mais ce n'est pas la
priorité
vraiment défendre ce pion parce que pour
le coup le pion peu serait très drôle et
maintenant il peut aller chercher le pur
à 4 et juste avant c'est sur le petit
roy est le plus grand en plus qu à gaz
de promotion et les scouts mais par le
fou qui va courir très vite depuis et
les blancs jouent de manière vraiment
acide et ils ont même oublié leur tour
donc finalement allé j'ai même pas vu la
fourchette mais ça revient à abandonner
toute façon de rentrer là dedans à ce
que d'ici le fou va juste il domine
complètement ce cavalairois qu'il a
aucune casse le cavalier il va devoir
sacrifier sur le pion parce que sinon si
tu y vas courir à damas plasan joue
vraiment tout seul
ici on a même un quatre contre trois
elle est allée le roi et le pion est
devenu même inarrêtable donc leur a pas
besoin de s'employer il va juste faire
dame et finalement les blues ont perdu
parce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé le pur
plan dans cette partie
ils n'ont pas su jouer contre le fou qui
était très beau mais ils l'ont libéré et
c'est leur a coûté la victoire
et vous regarde à nouveau la tête et ses
balades vertes qui a cinq points
d'avancé sur will crush ue reste encore
une dizaine de minutes donc ça peut
tourner on va voir le tournoi est ici
mais c'est vraiment la fin on dit qu'on
va voir si si je trouve balade verte où
il crèche ou parce que tout va se jouer
maintenant on reste en prison à l'heure
où je vous regarde et une autre partie
en attendant n'a pas regardé ces joueurs
là où plus on arrive pile au début entre
gnk la petite mobile tribe et manuel
aguiar qui a eu notre petit noble stream
c'est la bataille blisstree mienne avec
une avancée très précoce de piau h
mais kia moyens publics de réagir contre
l'option de questions surgissent et
souvent des mondes hésite pas à
déstabiliser deux filles ses traits à la
bad même niveau les meilleurs poèmes
beaucoup balancé le pion à vous poser
tout de suite des problèmes g5 c'est une
réaction assez surprenante
maintenant les dépenses est sourde ou f4
et depuis on a chip peut se retrouver
très faibles après l'échangé alors voir
mandela à cavalier c6
du coup beaucoup d'options pour pour
gêne ici avec les blancs une veine bien
évidemment avec d'arbres et de grand
roque mais fkt vraiment une idée
important non sur deux positions leurs
cavaliers f6 menace cavaliers g4 en fait
on serait très heureux de réussir à
manger le foot recasement adverse
le fou quasiment dans ses positions
c'est une pièce avec un hors jeu
vraiment important et du coup f3 s'est
très bien joué ils contrôlent cette case
du cavalier y consolider son simple et
il se laisse une case de retrait
potentiel d'une greffe prince c'est le
bon coup et petit roy qui n'a pas peur
bien peur et devra calculer des fous
pranger savent car bordeaux n'est avec
du hasch cheese le professeur heck elle
a extrêmement dangereux qui est le
contre attaquer mais ne vous prends g5
elle est juste de gagner mon avion voir
si peu fou mais il n'a pas peur gérad il
l'a jouée et maintenant h is a complete
sens erika valley and his il aurait
fallu jouer à chis tout de suite la
série casse du repli pour le coup c'est
vrai chute et ensuite on aurait pris ce
qu'ils ont sur échec
ça fait toute la différence de prendre
le pion sur échec parce que maintenant
on a chassé la dame et du coup ils
organisent à un blocus
la différence c'est qu'au lieu d'avoir
le fourrage suite dont le fils a même
pris ce boom c'est bien joué par exemple
on a peut-être on peut sacrifier la
capitaine est ce que je dis c'est tout
un jeu habile et du dap g7 heureusement
ils à tours j'ai vite intervenir qui
parle bat là il va devoir jouer et à b2
pour pouvoir reprendre la tour donc avec
les blancs c'était vraiment bien de
sacrifier le fou mais derrière hilal
s'est un peu précipité
cech maintenant la balance matériel il
ya il ya une qualité pour un an d'option
est le plus réussi c'est quand même
assez fort le g5 sait très bien jouer il
va échanger les dames en disant que le
plus machiste qui étaient très forts
avec les dames ça crée toujours des
réseaux de bâtard la somme alors il a
ripé la mauvaise nouvelle de bergues
parti comme ça le pion à celle ci serait
devenue femme plutôt une faiblesse en
finale alors on a toujours à wil crush
ue qui a doublé malades verte et a
certainement eu une ou deux parties il a
pris trois points d'avancé qui a perdu
une partie
on va voir si will cruciaux fini le
travail et on va regarder huy chrh où il
commence juste à partie avec les blancs
entre fusée galaxie respect du côté
blanc du pompeux et encore une fois le
fameux match 4 à damas doit par contre à
6 et 6 pas une paire convaincu a
certainement qui doit jouer ce genre de
système ça me paraît un petit peu lent
je suis pas sûr de saisir l'utilité du
pion à 6 par rapport au pire on a sept
élèves à se faire enfermer son fou
immédiatement classé d'une façon très
regrettable en matière de perdre et
surtout passer à sa portée fusée galaxie
ça il peut le voir qui jouent contre
ajoie très fort et en plus il a loué la
partie avec handicap et du coup il a
tilté a trop de pression là c'est
tout bénef pour notre leader parce qu'il
a gagné en moins dix coups donc je
crains qu'il ne devienne irrattrapable
beaucoup trop vite ce petit will
cruciaux quel parti va regarder j'en
avais témoin encore didus masters contre
cubier ricky les qui tout compte pas qui
on arrive pile au début sur une caisse
qui si on a une position de ces pics où
j'allais dire bonjour ou pour isoler
mais ça vient d'être d'être modifié et
encore une fois ce coup de cases
blanches a du mal à s'activer alors que
la mère se voit c'est très bien joué il
a fait sans attendre avec les plans du
semestre ' il a compris tout de suite
il replace en fou dans la grande
diagonale alors là ya pas eu de réaction
fallait aller jouer j'ai six pour pas
perdre l'option est une nouvelle fois le
droit qu'ils ont trop de retard de
développement
on me dit le pasteur pour l'instant qui
s'y joue très bien
on peut avoir comme l'idée de faire
passer la dap sur la crau panache pas
donc le bouclier achète la disparue
adams est un qui est intéressant aussi
pour vieux fou g5 le dernier défenseur
du roi que c'est se [ __ ] carte noire
donc si on arrive à les changer le roi
adverse sera bien dénuder pour bien
aussi janin vous qui peut être mauvais
goût mais une tour sur une colonne verte
on met une pression sur
faiblesses et là il peut peut-être pas
joué juste manière bassement
matérialistes en allant chercher
bessette n'est pas obligé de viser le
roi et la jac en tombent plus pauvres
ont géré en 2e les fous et 5 j'aime
beaucoup
il va manger du kala et du pion deçà de
chansons qui est chez steam mais je
préfère quand même le cavalier peut
peut-être amené la dame ensuite on voit
en fait la différence entre la juste les
pièces blanches les pièces noires on
coupe le fouga l'allier qui domine le
couple adverse
en plus du pion gratuit et du roi qui
n'est pas sans sécurité
vous avez beaucoup de de plus la ja
bessette a été abrogée ps est un livre
je me tape à chécy joue le ban c'est le
bouche de est dû ce masters ça a été vu
ou contre la chine peut-être on va
trouver du contre je me les comptes
silver il envoie et pas du tout
intéressé par les pions à l'aide d'armes
lui viser l'europe
alors si tu vas continuer avec h1n1 même
esprit finalement
switch us pour me contredire les
branches ps est patent moquer papa et ça
a complètement du sens à 100 et je ne
crains pas de partir des bus master pour
voir jouer à 1321 à grand chose à lui
reprocher sur cette partie avant s'il
arrive à rester aussi précis jusqu'au
bout alors ils sacrifient la pièce est
ce qu'il a prévu suroît progressis pas
certain d'être j4 les attentions apas
perdre des balles de set et argent
content qu'il ait produit si si si on va
voir est ce qu'il avait prévu
typiquement il avait une position et
razer d'ardeur dans une pièce où là il a
dû complètement oublié cet échange des
dames je les fais beaucoup trop de
compliments et du coup il a sacrifié une
pièce pourrait changer la donne
évidemment c'est deux choses qui ne vont
généralement pas car d'ensemble parce
que du coup il a apporté son attaque les
perdu son avantage matériel un maillage
et 4g qu'un qui daterait de récupérer la
pièce s'en sort bien avec les noix il
suffisait de manger le pion et où
demeurait avec une pièce d'art ans
du coup la partie rebascule plutôt en
faveur des blancs j'aime quand même de
plus il ya 7 qui va tomber ici suffit
juste de manger un même si la c3 qui est
perdu par la suite
alors ça c'est pas compréhensible il
oublié sa tour donc didier mastain qui
avait vraiment fait une très bonne
première phase deux parties ça c'est un
point de concentration et c'est aussi
peut-être pourquoi il a 7 et aulas ait
pas davantage
on sent qu'il est capable de très bons
pour faire juste de temps en temps il ya
une absence et ça pour que ça vous
arrive - bah c'est faux vous entraîner à
calculer après c'est pas aussi dans
quelles conditions je vais joueurs des
fois il ya des gens autour de nous qui
est discret peut-être que je les fais
stressé ouais j'ai enchaîné les
compliments il s'est mis à tout donner
en fait il a voulu faire le beau jeu on
a sacrifié la pièce cdd malheureusement
ça ne marchait pas comme je vois pas
trop riquiqui laisser échapper cette
partie là a priori
a priori c'est très facile et à ce
qu'une minute donc y aura certaines
n'ont pas le temps de relancer une autre
ce que ça donne au classement est-ce que
will crush ou à confirmer
il est quand même pas loin derrière
balade verte est en point seulement de
retard est-il en train de jouer enders
[Musique]
je vois une balade verte ou là qu'est ce
que c'est que cette position
l'essai de marquer des points coûte que
coûte balade verte sachant que le
tournoi va se terminer à ce qu'une
minute mais là c'est un peu la stratégie
font là là c'est trop trop de pch
il a carrément abandonné juste pour
essayer de relancer une nouvelle partie
de la scène position à avoir une
migraine il ya beaucoup trop de pièces
en prison du coup du coup il crush on y
sera il conserve ses trois points
d'avancé à part si balade verte nous
plantent un petit ban super g men 2
matchs du berger parce que maintenant il
parle plus que de points il arrivera pas
à le rattraper
est-ce qu'on termine par quelques et le
droit qui va du coup est certainement ne
pas perdre contre barbarians les deux
jours sur votre bulle est de foule près
nous ils ont 15 secondes s'est jamais
senti aussi mal qui peut traîner
barbarian il envoie tour mais c'est trop
tard mais bien essayé quand même du coup
oui à deux joueurs ont vraiment bien
dominé ce tournoi mais oui le crush on
est impressionnant c'était sa première
donc je vous rappel c'est un fou russe
18 victoires une seule défaite qui l'a
bien mérité car mérité sa victoire dans
cette arène balade mart est juste
derrière qui a prêché ya le plus de
parties mais du coup qui a pris plus de
risques il ya un peu plus de déchet donc
félicitations hana to we will cruciaux
et bah bravo à tous les participants
demain je crois que ces femmes
si je dis pas de bêtises
la sicav l aipis met ça dans le chat
alors combien joueurs on a eu quand même
sang neuf joueurs donc c'est pas mal
dépasse toujours la centaine et faire 18
parties elle devance cette fois déjà a
vraiment pris 1 min week end d'une
journée quoi
ok donc demain vous retrouverez baquet à
13 heures merci merci
le charlot merci à tous un peu si je te
porte chance
l'étape et je vous dis à bientôt tout le
monde va se passer un bon week end
ciao ciao